on est là
[Musique]
on le découvre au sein du saïan supa
crew comme beat boxer trois albums de
disques d'or et une victoire de la
musique
sa carrière est lancée qui n'ont plus
rien
[Musique]
il collabore ensuite avec de nombreux
artistes comme camille pour son album le
fils en 2005
en parallèle ce lie de vin sly johnson
et entame une carrière solo avec son
premier album 74 en 2010 depuis il fait
pleinement partie de la scène musicale
française où il mélange les genres entre
hip hop jazz et soul j'espère que gamin
musique symbolise le mélange entre kas
et j'aime ça j'aime les rencontres
j'aime les mélanges
donc c'est ce que je fais depuis toutes
ces années ci et le public me ressemble
en tout cas c'est une bonne chose
c'est mon intention en tout cas son
prochain album ça en 2019 un réel retour
aux sources pour l'artiste originaire de
montrouge dans les hauts de seine pour
faire patienter son public il a déjà
sorti un ep le 28 septembre dernier avec
trois titres inédits dont skin ce qui me
parle en fait de de cet épisode en école
primaire où je me retrouvais avec tous
les autres enfants dans la cour de récré
est l'un d'eux malheureusement traité de
sale noir voilà et c'est ce jour là
moi je les prix comme ça que j'ai appris
j'étais noir du banc donc je raconte
cette histoire
dans le morceau ce crime sly johnson se
produira à la batterie à guyancourt ce 6
octobre et à la cigale à paris le 16
octobre
le moral est accompli il ne s'en est
fort tout au long de mon effort
merde
[Musique]